what's going on guys this is rob and i
felt like covering neil gaiman's
eternals and the reason why is because
looking at the trailer that we've seen
recently and really it looks like a lot
of the stuff that we're going to see in
the movie is going to be based on what
neil gaiman did in his eternals run now
here's the thing neil gaiman's eternals
is designed to kind of explain why it is
that we haven't seen the eternals for a
really long time in marvel comics
because this takes place during civil
war and prior to this point we really
hadn't seen the eternals for a while and
so it was a really really cool way to
kind of fold this in and so what this
does is it initially picks up with a guy
by the name of mark curry now this guy
has what are basically kind of like
these flashback memories these moments
where he experiences something from his
past but he's not really sure what it is
and even for him it seems like kind of a
nightmare now this will become important
later on down the line when he kind of
when we kind of get like the backstory
and everything but what he's basically
having dreams of is the war between the
eternals and the deviants and then the
arrival of the celestials in the middle
of that war and what was basically the
great cataclysm right the sinking of
atlantis and so this is cool because in
the middle of all this he suddenly met
by the arrival of icarus now one thing
to know is that icarus doesn't fully
know who he is right and that's going to
become a major plot point throughout
this video at least this kind of being
the first part of the story we'll cover
the second part in the second video
icarus doesn't fully know who he is mark
curry doesn't fully know who he is so a
lot of this is really just kind of
discovery right now icarus has a much
better idea of who he is than mark curry
does but that's why he keeps saying like
have you ever wondered where humanity
came from and different things like that
the reality is that icarus looks like a
crazy guy but he shows up at this dude's
hospital first and foremost like
pestering him talking about hey man like
have you ever wondered where everything
in existence came from you ever wonder
who made everything that's there it's
what you would expect like a jehovah's
witness to show up on your doorstep and
ask at like seven o'clock in the morning
right are you prepared for the
celestial's return
that kind of a thing and he even shows
up on the guy like like outside the
guy's apartment right outside his
brownstone in new york right knocking on
his window and asking him like hey or
have you thought anything about what
i've told you you know have you ever
wondered about the origins of
intelligent life on this planet it's
just kind of crazy stuff now at that
point you switch over to cersei and
cersei of course is kind of living out
this life where she is pretty awesome
right it's just cersei doing cersei's
stuff you get this little bit of a tour
with regards to these eternals who are
basically here living out their lives
all the while seemingly completely
oblivious to the fact that they are
actually eternal they don't seem to know
who they are they don't seem to know
what they're capable of or what they can
do the closest thing that you really get
here is this moment where you kind of
have a sort of session between athena
and icarus but it really seems to be
just kind of a general discussion
between the two while they do look like
eternals it almost kind of seems to be a
flashback to a degree and so one of the
things that happens is that in the
middle of all this icarus is suddenly
attacked by these two just guys right
look like thugs that kind of a thing
they will become
very important later on in the story but
for right now they're just a couple of
guys who are giving you know icarus a
hard time in fact they actually throw
him down into a net and then throw a
bomb down there with him and then try to
blow him up but at that point you switch
over to ivan druid right now ivan drew
at this point in time is really kind of
a military slash representative of a
nation known as verazzeka i think is how
you pronounce it or vorazega whatever it
is it's one of the former soviet
countries right those you guys weren't
really familiar with that back when you
had the ussr like during and after world
war ii you had what was essentially just
a whole bunch of of smaller countries
which have been conquered by the soviet
union and they were all just kind of
unified under the banner of the ussr
with the collapse of the soviet union
the fall of the berlin wall and all that
kind of stuff nikita khrushchev losing
all his power that what you had what was
basically the soviet bloc dismantling
and so a lot of those countries that had
previously been really ruled by the
soviet union had now become
self-governing and so in the marvel
comics basically vorzeka is one of those
places right so in the real world there
were a lot of them that were there so a
lot of them just haven't recovered but
the important thing is that's where this
place comes from now the reality of this
is again much like the other people who
are here druid does not know who he is
instead his working with cersei is kind
of interesting because they've known
each other for like a million years but
they don't know that they've known each
other for a million years and that's why
they're talking like strangers
instead the idea here is to work with
cersei to actually organize a party uh
that's basically gonna be held at the
embassy of vorzika for the purpose of
helping to kind of drum up tourism to
show people this is a place where they
want to travel to it's really geared
more towards the rich and the powerful
right because when it comes to any
organized society specifically american
society if the rich and the powerful do
it those who are not rich and powerful
will likely follow suit in order to
appear rich and powerful or to kind of
get a taste of the lives of the rich and
the powerful and so it's a pretty smart
move if only for diplomatic reasons but
following that you switch over to mark
curry who basically responds to the
emergency room uh emergency room call
anyway about this guy who basically is
supposed to be blown up he should be
dead right this guy's got fractures he's
got he's got you know burns and all
kinds of stuff only to find out that
it's icarus you switch over momentarily
to tony stark to iron man as he meets
with athena now iron man and then have a
very lengthy history together but again
like the other eternals tina doesn't
really know who she is instead as she's
performing these kind of weapon
experiments creating a bomb that can
blind people things like that then it
all comes to her exceedingly easily
because while it is basically in her
nature to do it she doesn't realize it
right so it's like if you spoke spanish
all your life and then forgot that your
ability to learn spanish would be much
much easier than a person who's never
learned spanish in their life because
what you're doing is basically drawing
on your subconscious right you're
drawing on something you already know
you just don't know that you know it and
so because of this athena kind of makes
this offhanded remark that it was really
really easy you know just like
remembering but this little bit of an
exchange will become important later but
switching back over to icarus this is
when you get at least a partial spilling
of the beans with regards to everything
it's kind of funny the way this happens
because when i was reading through this
i was like okay one of two things is
happening either icarus doesn't remember
how things were supposed to happen or
neil gaiman's messing with us
neil gaiman's changing things up so
icarus is going to give us the
explanation here but i'm going to kind
of fill you in on how things actually
are but right now the way that icarus
says this is about somewhere around a
million years ago that the celestials
had arrived on earth now for those of
you guys who are familiar with all of
this because we have talked about it
before bear with me because i think a
lot of people are going to be seeing
this and have no idea what's going on
here but about a million years before
the modern day the celestials showed up
on earth now the celestials visiting
earth was part of a grand cosmic
experiment right they literally did it
across the entirety of the universe in
more recent years especially during al
ewing's ultimates marvel sort of shifted
up the origins of the celestials
themselves which it might behoove us to
do an updated origins of the celestials
video uh just because of the fact that a
lot of significant things have changed
what al ewing did doesn't really have a
bearing on what's happening here uh so
that's why we'll probably make a
separate video but the important thing
is that as the celestials came into
existence or really entered into this
universe they spread across the whole
universe and basically seeded worlds now
depending on what story you're talking
about neil gaiman's keeping it pretty
contained here one of the things that
that marvel's done over the years is
introduced the idea that everything that
exists in the universe outside of the
cosmic entities and galactus right so
all the solar systems all the galaxies
all the planets stars all that kind of
stuff that was all created by the
celestials other people have said and
other writers have said that those
things just kind of formed naturally as
they do in a universe and all the
celestials did is exactly what you see
them doing here showing up on worlds and
seeding it with life regardless of how
you slice it though the important thing
is that whether the celestials seeded
these worlds with life or life already
existed the celestials would travel
around the universe to different worlds
and they would experiment on the
denizens of that world in the case of
earth what had happened is the
celestials had basically taken a group
called the wonders now one of the things
that neil gaiman is leading out here and
it's probably pretty intelligent to do
this is that technically if you go and
you read the old jack kirby eternal
stuff that it was actually gaia the
sentience of earth and the biological
mother of thor that had led these
individuals to the celestials themselves
but the thing about this is the
celestials basically took a small
portion of humanity at the time and they
split them into thirds and then
following that they started modifying
their genes one third of humanity had
their genes augmented so they would
basically achieve god-like power and
that's where the eternals came from the
ability to tap into cosmic energies and
to essentially do anything they want to
as well as immortality insofar as if
their physical body is destroyed they
can be brought back they can be
resurrected essentially what you had is
the eternals just kind of created an
existing as an absolute number that
could never grow beyond the existing
number that were created by these
celestials now with the second third of
humanity's genes being destabilized that
created the deviance the big difference
here between the eternals and the
deviants is that the eternals all
essentially look alike the deviants are
all completely different so it'd be like
if i took 100 of you guys and i modified
your genes and then basically turned
each one of you into a different race
that was completely and totally
different than any of the other races
around you the big kicker to this and
neil gaiman doesn't really explain how
somehow they managed to find a way to
procreate now because they were able to
do that they spread across the world so
fast their numbers increased by the
millions now neil gaiman kind of ends it
there and basically says like there was
a great big war that broke out between
the eternals and the deviants and so on
and so forth so let's fill in a few gaps
right let's kind of expand this a little
bit and offer some more explanation in
terms of the things that he doesn't
cover here so one of the things to know
is that the last third of humanity had
their genes modified so that at some
future point in time they would develop
powers and that's how marvel explains
why it is that bruce banner was just
like hit with gamma radiation and
instead of becoming this giant mass of
irradiated tumors like he did in marvel
ruins that instead he becomes the
incredible hulk it explains why it is
that some kid in a classroom somewhere
can go through a heightened level of
stress or start entering into puberty
and then suddenly an x gene activates
and they're just another mutant out
there now because of the fact that
humanity or at least that third of
humanity didn't have powers at that
point in time what it led to was the
deviants essentially subjugating them
right conquering them and then turning
them into a kind of slave labor during
that time the war between the eternals
and the deviants broke out and the
deviants operated out of the capital
city of lumeria in atlantis and so when
this giant war took place and the
eternals realized how hopelessly
outnumbered they were that they couldn't
continue fighting the deviants without
risking being destroyed themselves that
what they did is they contacted the
celestials and the celestials returned
only to find out the deviants had
basically deviated away from the role
that was originally created for them by
the celestials now the eternals did the
same thing right it wasn't until this
war broke out that the eternals cared
about what was going on with humanity
when the deviants struck first that's
when the eternal started getting
involved and so what you saw was the
great cataclysm the celestials basically
annihilating the deviants almost to the
point of complete and total extinction
they reduced their numbers down to a few
thousand and their population never came
back from that and then in turn it
allowed humanity to flourish because the
celestials then turned to the eternals
and said if you basically move away from
protecting humanity again we'll destroy
you all right we will we'll wipe
everything out we'll cleanse the whole
world and we'll call it a day now this
is kind of the explanation of how it all
took place right this great big conflict
that initially unfolded and so that's
why you have icarus basically speaking
with uh with mike curry and saying your
name is actually makari that's your real
name here and the idea is that we as
eternals once the deviants were
basically defeated and we essentially
started following what it was the
celestials told us to do we started
shepherding humanity we taught them how
to grow how to flourish we taught them
how to how to plant grain we taught them
how to work with metals we taught
society everything it would need to
become productive and this is the marvel
explanation as to how it is that the
capital city of lumeria in atlantis and
the earth itself could be such a
gigantic thriving you know place right
with all kinds of trade and commerce and
you know advanced technologies and
things like that and then after the
great cataclysm humanity essentially
appeared to start over again because it
did right humanity was pushed to the
near brink of extinction baseline humans
were really the only ones left the
deviants had basically gone underground
and because humanity had largely been
used as a kind of a slave labor force
they weren't really properly educated
and so during that time you know during
this whole era it really was almost like
starting from zero so it's very
aristotelian right in terms of how this
whole thing goes down but with this
whole explanation being given to uh to
makari he's kind of okay this is crazy
talk right like none of what you're
telling me makes any sense whatsoever
and it seems absolutely ridiculous and
so what actually ends up happening is a
couple guys show up the same guys that
actually tried to blow him up uh they
seem to show up here and then of course
he's handed over to those guys with
makari not really knowing what it is
that he's doing and so during that time
a few things unfold the first is that
makari continues to kind of endure these
sort of flashbacks to a degree but while
icarus is being held captive he actually
telepathically communicates with makari
asking him to find a way to free him to
save him and to get him out of there
because those guys are essentially going
to kill him as far as cersei goes while
she's there doing her thing at this
great big huge party what you have is
actually druid and a lot of people who
are who are present here and the whole
thing pops off when like these armed
terrorists come running in start
attacking the place snatching up the
scientists with the intention of racing
off and and so on and so forth and
during that whole time you actually have
what is in effect the formation of a
unimod now the unimon forming here is
really kind of a smaller version of what
it normally is and for those of you guys
who don't know what that is the unimide
is something you only ever really see
when eternals come together due to the
fact that like a gigantic decision needs
to be made and no one eternal is
equipped to make it on their own so say
for example that like something happened
the deviants had like overran the world
there was no way for the eternals to get
a hold of the celestials and they said
okay we have to like obliterate the
earth you know in order to stop the
deviants from like spreading into the
cosmos or something something like that
i don't know i'm just using some example
what would happen here is they would
form the unimine to one know whether it
was actually the right decision to make
and two if it were the decision that
they made blood would be on all their
hands because they made it as a singular
cohesive unit and so with that being the
case because this minor unimine is
formed a handful of things happen the
first is that mike curry realizes he is
makari that he can move at hyper speed
and so following that what you end up
doing is switching over to iron man who
basically you know appears on the scene
right in the midst of all this chaos and
all this insanity and the funny thing is
that while cersei has woken up to this
idea that there seems to be something
going on with her to a degree realizing
what's happening she doesn't fully grasp
it instead what actually ends up
happening here is iron man takes cersei
to the side seems to say something to
her and then basically leaves now the
reality of this is there are some people
here that have powers but none of them
want to act and the reason why is
because most anybody here who has powers
is likely unregistered remember this
takes place during the events of civil
war or really in the aftermath of civil
war tony stark's essentially one he's
director of shield but superhuman
registration is still in effect and so
if you are an unregistered superhero you
can either register or you can be thrown
into the prison in the negative zone
where you'll just be left to rot
basically and so because of that none of
these guys really want anybody to know
that they have powers but the crazy
thing is a lot of this is really kind of
coming from makari who's basically
recounting everything that's going on
here and the funny thing about this is
that this whole recollection of what's
been going on seems to be in the process
of being recounted to sprite now the
crazy thing about this is we don't
definitively know that it's sprite right
in fact we'll find out a little bit more
about that here in a second but
regarding these two guys who had
kidnapped icarus and are basically
torturing him and experimenting on him
you end up finding out that of course
these guys are deviants more so than
that what they're actually doing is they
are reading from what's called the book
of krask and this is particularly
important because what this book says is
that and then the golden one the
greatest of all the celestials he who
had created the changing people at times
dawn he who rose up against his fellows
let my people be he said for did i not
give them dominion over the earth and
all that is upon it but the other
celestials turned on him and tricked him
they swore to him that they would leave
the changing people in peace they were
oath breakers then and thus it is
written the oath of a celestial is
written on the winds of space and he's
shown like the sun but after they
betrayed him he was blacker than tar
they buried him for they could not kill
him beneath the earth our dreadlord lies
dreaming yet all things change and so
what these guys are basically talking
about is the dreaming celestial right
tiamu or tiamat it depends on who you're
talking to i always call them tiamou the
dreaming celestial here's something to
understand this guy is powerful team of
dreaming celestials on a whole different
level than virtually anybody else that
you've seen in involving the celestials
themselves like in this hierarchy of
celestials this guy's way beyond them
now there are a couple of things that
happen here that are worth mentioning
but are not overly important for example
druid realizes because he can kind of
manipulate the minds of others by
basically screwing with their memories
or their experiences tormenting them by
their own life history that what he does
is start to realize he can rise through
the ranks and actually rule this country
that he represents the second thing that
happened is he actually orchestrated the
terrorist attack but instead of simply
just kidnapping the scientists that one
of the people that was working alongside
him turned against him so when he visits
this guy he basically tells this guy to
kill himself and that's essentially it
but then you switch over to thena of
course is being held as one of the
scientists by this you know this this
group essentially led by druid himself
and during this this whole event where
she's being held captive she suddenly
realizes how deadly she is right that
she can use anything as a weapon because
she's the most prodigious fighter of all
the eternals it's the reason why in
marvel comics in the early days of
humanity during the days of like greek
gods and all that kind of stuff fina was
oftentimes considered to be the earthly
embodiment of athena right the greek
goddess of of like you know conflict or
war wisdom or whatever it is that she
was known for but the important thing is
that thina immediately starts realizing
on who she is right okay so like i'm
thena i'm an eternal i'm basically the
best fighter of all the eternals so she
immediately contacts tony stark knowing
who he is and she's like can you home in
on this number he's like yeah she's like
get here as fast as you can so he
basically races over there takes all
these guys out gets a hold athena and
then basically flies off icarus after
having essentially been killed is
properly resurrected and so now that
he's properly resurrected the actual
resurrection process takes place and so
far as all his memories of everything
are restored to him now that's an
important thing that happens when it
comes to the eternals it's something
that kieron gillen's modified a little
bit in recent years during his eternals
run but the important thing here is that
when an eternal dies when they're
resurrected and they're brought back
they're a clean slate you can put
anything in their brains that you want
to right like icarus could come back and
the machine could be like actually
you're the state puff marshmallow man
and we need you to go attack new york
right that's and he would believe it
right because he's basically a shell
right it's like pouring water into into
a cup right whatever you pour into that
cup that's what that cup will be a cup
of milk a cup of water a cup of tea and
so because of this it's a very very
interesting process but potentially also
a dangerous one the benefit here is that
every ounce of knowledge every
experience that the eternals have is
backed up it's actually what jonathan
hickman essentially copied when it came
to kokoa in the x-men comics right the
fact that the x-men back up everything
that had happened to every mutant across
the world so long as they've been to
krakowa so that if they happen to be
resurrected they have their memories up
until that point they can be changed and
modified but they're basically the same
thing that that's what's happening with
icarus his memories are being restored
to him and so as makari is spending time
talking to this little kid the first
thing he asks is like are you an eternal
right this kid's like no i'm not an
eternal i promise you like i am not an
eternal i'm a human right like i'm a
human person i have no powers no
abilities whatsoever which really begs
the question how does he know so much
about the eternals because he tells
makari like touch that black rock over
there right we'll find out if you're an
eternal or not touch that black rock and
we'll see what happens when he touches
that rock immediately this doorway opens
and basically lowers them down into uh
into this kind of you know basement type
area underground in san francisco and as
this kid talks to him right he's kind of
like okay so here's the thing the next
test of whether or not you're an eternal
is to attack that giant black wall over
there right like charge that thing as
fast as you can he's like for me i don't
do anything if i try to charge it but
you charge it and let's see what happens
and so like when makari goes to hit the
wall before he can even touch it he's
kind of pushed back by this this sort of
energy field and then is unable to
actually do anything to the rock and
that's when this kid starts messing with
him he's like god you guys are so such
idiots like that is not a giant black
rock that's the dreaming celestial right
that's how big the dreamy celestial is
this guy's miles tall but what this kid
reveals is that he is actually sprite
and the reason why the eternals can't
remember anything is because of what
sprite did that when the celestials
showed up on earth in the early days
right like a million years ago and they
modified the genes of one third of
humanity and made them eternals one of
them was sprite that he was a kid whose
genes were modified he was given
god-like powers the issue with this is
that by and large with the eternals
their evolution is frozen in place
they'll never grow right they'll never
get older they are by all standards of
measurement immortal and perfect and so
the biggest issue that uh that sprite
had with this is he will never age what
really pissed him off is that apparently
like cersei has just like banged
everybody right she's like he's like
yeah man like every single like eternal
dude she slept with somewhere along the
line he's like but she'll never sleep
with me because i'm like 11.
he even approached her at one point and
tried to see if she wanted to knock
boots and she was like no i mean you're
11. that's that's not gonna happen and
so ultimately that combined with the
fact that he's been 11 years old for a
million years was enough for him to just
not want to have anything to do with
this the only thing he could really do
was find enjoyment and messing with
people right so like showing up to a guy
in 1901 out on a park bench and claimed
to be peter pan and actually setting the
stage for the story that became peter
pan right like the character of peter
pan in in literature it's based off of a
sprite basically messing with a guy
right all that kind of stuff and so the
idea here of sprite was to essentially
strip down and to eliminate the
possibility of eternals being what they
are and to actually revert them back to
humans but that's not something you can
easily do if sprite had kind of jumped
into a campaign using his ability to
create illusions and said actually we're
all humans and called it a day it never
would have worked instead what happened
here is that there was a scenario where
a unimine was formed and sprite was part
of it right it was necessary for sprite
to be a part of this unimine in order to
basically fix you know the aftermath of
this giant earthquake and and so on and
so forth the important thing here is
that sprite realized given the power of
the unimine because it can alter the
genetic structure the memories the whole
nine yards of eternals he can use that
to his own ends and so over the course
of
years and we're not really given a
definitive amount of time we're told
that it's like thousands and thousands
of years that what he did is he actually
began to manipulate the eternals so when
an eternal died and they were brought
back he would make a modification to
their memories here that when another
eternal died and they were brought back
he'd make a modification there if they
die and come back enough times suddenly
this entire memory bank that they have
right everything they recall is full of
false memories and that's what he says
he's like in a hundred years there's a
lot of illusion that you can create you
can give people memories that aren't
theirs you can make them forget things
they always knew you can make people
forget things that are true and believe
things that are not a little illusion
goes such a long way he says it took a
whole lot of work and he's talking about
more work than he ever would have
believed to have been possible but he
said when i was done i went down to the
reactivation chamber i took xeros the
most powerful of us ajax the only one
who could talk to the celestials and i
brought them here i couldn't make the
archive reactivate them fully without
bringing back all the frozen dead but it
was enough what he did here is he
basically took xeros and he took ajax he
brought them here to the dreaming
celestial and then he performed a unimod
using those two eternals and the
dreaming celestial which basically gave
him the power to do anything he wanted
to he and that's one of the things he
says like i could have done anything i
wanted to i could have made snow taste
like chocolate right i could have have
made the rivers run red i could have
done anything that i wanted to in
existence but the only thing i ever
wanted to do was to be human and so
using the power of the dreaming
celestial he essentially stripped away
the eternal's knowledge of who they were
and then reduce them down to being
humans and so that's one of the crazy
things here is that because of that
everything that's happening here has all
been done at the hands of sprite the
greatest rouge that sprites ever done
more so than that what you actually end
up doing is switching over to icarus
when he goes to see thena and once tina
begins to really understand who she is
all these memories of her actual life as
an eternal start flooding back she's met
by the arrival of icarus and he's like
he just kind of hangs there for a second
and then he's like do you know who i am
and she says yes and he says we have to
go now and when she asks where he says
it's the deviants they're going to wake
the dreaming celestial and if they do
they will kill the world and they will
when the dreaming celestial or if the
dreaming celestial ever were to wake up
and it does things are crazy to give you
guys a little bit of a taste of what
we're gonna cover in this next video
when the dreaming celestial wakes up
there's one line in the comic where it
says that like the universe shakes in a
way that it hasn't done in millions of
years and for the first time in a long
time galactus knows what it's like to
feel fear
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with eternals covering neil
gaiman's run and the dreaming celestial
has awakened right the most powerful
celestial of all the celestials who have
ever existed in the history of marvel
comics this guy is op okay so here's the
thing the initial part of this kind of
focuses on the idea of like grabbing
eternals and kind of waking them up or
at least the ones they can anyway there
is a bit of a moment when sprite is
brought before those two deviants who
would basically try to torture and
torment icarus and ultimately killed him
and then in turn he was resurrected
basically his fright runs away right
like sprite gets away and that's that's
kind of the end of that at that point
you end up picking up with ajax now
remember ajax is one of the more
important eternals who exist out there
the reason for this is because ajax
historically has been the speaker to the
celestials which is to say of all the
eternals who exist out there ajax the
only one that can ever really talk to
them now the question you're probably
asking yourself is why is ajak a dude
when in the movies ajax is a chick so in
reality from most of ajax history he was
a guy right that was always the case
ajak was a guy it wasn't until during
kieran gillen's run and eternals volume
5 which we covered and we kind of talked
about this that marvel changed it up the
incontinuity answer is that because
eternals have just been alive for like a
million years it's not uncommon for an
eternal to just shift things up and to
come back as a woman instead of a guy
i'm sure a lot of people out there who
are always looking for a reason to be
upset will take this as a reason to be
angry i mean it's comic books why would
you get pissed it's literally stories of
fiction
but that's kind of the way that that
kind of or at least that ajax
historically existed now the role of
ajax as the speaker to the celestials
will actually change drastically here
and it's going to be a pretty
significant moment for the character of
ajax but at the moment if you guys
recall ajak and xeros were the ones who
were used by sprite to basically tap
into the power of the dreaming celestial
by essentially creating a unimined and
then making all the eternals mortal in
the first place and so ajax being here
and communicating with xeros is one of
these things where zoros doesn't really
know exactly what's going on right xeros
is basically just a homeless guy which
is kind of weird that the leader of the
eternals would now be homeless it is
kind of a antithesis to the role that he
previously played but the important
thing here is that ajax tells xeros you
have to wake up right you're our leader
you're the greatest of us the dreaming
celestial is returning now the funny
thing about this is that neil gaiman
sort of plays it fast and loose that
unlike previous instances when you had
like druid or cersei or somebody like
that where they unwittingly performed a
unimined and then woke themselves up to
the reality of who they were that xerox
doesn't really get that and in fact
guymon kind of plays it with this idea
that like zoros sort of already knows
who he is but he's kind of shying away
from it to a degree perhaps some kind of
test or something along those lines but
it's one of these things where as soon
as ajax says like you have to come back
uh the dreaming celestial is going to be
awoken and the horde is going to come to
earth suddenly xeros is up and his eyes
light up and he was like ajax you know
he's like i'm an eternal and so it may
just be the idea of the dreaming
celestial the threat of the horde what
it represents the fact that basically it
would lead to the destruction of all
life on earth and in fact this entire
part of the galaxy itself it's enough to
just kind of jog him awake and if that
is the case it's really a testament to
the power of the horde and we'll talk
about them later on because the horde
are hugely significant right they're
really really interesting and they're
crazy powerful but at that point you
switch over to druid now remember druid
is the one who was basically the deputy
prime minister for the nation of ruseka
and now he's the one that essentially
rules it and the idea behind this is
that because there were individuals
working behind the scenes to destroy him
to cast off his rules so on and so forth
that what he does is he basically splits
them among the loyal and the disloyal
and what he does is he tells the people
who are loyal if you want to truly
demonstrate that you are a part of this
of this government of this empire if you
truly want to demonstrate that you are
loyal to me then here's a box cutter and
he's like you'll have to kill like you
have to kill one of those people who are
traitors it doesn't matter who they are
but you have to kill one now one of
these guys initially goes after druid
and of course druid uses his powers to
make this guy cut his own throat and
it's one of these things where he kind
of does this as a demonstration and
saying either you can die by my hands or
you can die at the hands of my guards or
you can die by any number of ways or you
can kill those traitors one way or
another people are dying today right so
like there's no way for you to really
destroy me and the result is that the
loyal kill the disloyal right they kill
the traitors and then from that point
going on what this does is it's twisted
as it is it creates a kind of
unification even if the unification is
only out of fear when people are looking
at individuals out there who are
traitors and they haven't taken the
lives of those traitors they can still
call themselves good guys they can still
call themselves heroes but once they
cross that line once they kill them now
they're all unified in blood right every
one of them looks at the other and they
know what they did there's no way to
avoid that there's no way to look away
from it or to hide from it that's who
they are as people and that's the
reality right when it comes down to it
when people are given a choice when
they're put in a corner that they feel
like they can't get out of they will
show you who they really are and in this
instance the idea the desire to survive
is overwhelming in comparison to the
morality of taking out these traitors so
they take out the traitors because
that's who people really are right if
people come when it comes down to it if
a person has to kill you to stay alive
they will do it and so again kind of
switching over to these uh these
deviants who again have makari sort of
contained here and using him as a vector
to wake up the the dreaming celestial
they provide a little bit of history
here and one of the funny things about
this when it came to the deviants is
that the mythos behind them especially
during the roy thomas days to a degree
the dan jurgens days but with the roy
thomas days what you got here was this
kind of explanation that was pretty
straightforward really kind of building
on what kirby did but it was like the
celestial showed up on earth and they
basically called a huge portion of the
deviants to the point that they were
almost pushed to extinction because the
deviants had essentially conquered
humanity and attacked the celestials
when the celestials showed up and that
was it right no must no fuss instead
what you get is the other side of that
coin the way in which the deviants view
the celestials after all this had
happened and because they really follow
what is in effect uh largely a
theocratic society in the sense that
they believed in the celestials as gods
and so on and so forth that they had
taken this idea of them being destroyed
due to their hubris turned it on its
head and they see themselves as what is
basically an energy source that satiates
the the celestials right they see
themselves as almost kind of these
divine beings to a degree more so than
that they see the dreaming celestial as
a being that actually try to save them
and so they really worship the dreaming
celestial more so than anything else and
we'll get a bit of an explanation about
that here in a little while but it is a
cool thing because that's how the
deviants function now from there you
actually switch over to cersei and abby
now remember cersei and abby are friends
right there is a kind of indication
there that there was a bit of romantic
history and it would make sense with
cersei i mean the way this chick is if
it walks on two legs she's probably
slept with it and so there's a whole lot
of her just kind of doing that over the
years right during that time or at least
during this segment here icarus shows up
meets with cersei and then actually
wipes the mind of abby so abby will
never remember who any of them are now
at this point it's crushing to cersei
because cersei didn't really know who
she was she had a life that she enjoyed
here she didn't know she wasn't eternal
all that kind of stuff and even after
coming to that revelation in the last
video that we talked about where she
basically realized she had powers and
that after a conversation with iron man
and their history there that she really
does seem to be an eternal she actually
shied away from it she didn't want to
have anything to do with it she's like
okay i mean maybe that's true but i like
my life here i don't want to stay here i
want to do this thing but icarus kind of
puts her in a position to where she has
to confront this now you do also have
theena and her son joey who are there
and of course that is the actual
biological son of fina which is the
result of fina basically being human and
being able to procreate where eternals
normally are incapable of doing that
with the quote unquote spell being
broken the dreaming celestial being
woken up them coming to the reality of
who they are the indication seems to be
their genetic structure goes back to
being to that of the of an eternal as
opposed to somebody just being a human
but regardless of how you slice it the
important thing is that abby's kind of
left behind now the promise that's made
here if cersei goes with icarus the
promise that's made is that abby will be
able to go back to remembering who they
were that cersei can actually give her
that but the important thing here is
that druid's aid is also needed because
there's so few eternals here that being
able to muster a force capable of at
least challenging the dreaming celestial
or bringing you know keeping him from
coming up it requires all this all the
eternals to act in unison largely
because a unimined is going to be needed
the bargain that's made between xeros
and druid is that in order for druid to
step up and to be willing to act that
the entirety of druik's nation has to
basically be left alone that it's one of
these things where i will help you but
basically my nation is wholly my own you
will never come here you will never
cause conflicts here no matter what i do
here you will never step in and the
bargain that's made is okay right like
that's it xeros goes with it and the
reason why is because xerox needs druid
more than druid needs xerox right i mean
i guess they all kind of knew each other
together but at the end of the day it's
a pretty good move made on on druid's
part right and that's kind of always
been his character manipulation
subterfuge things like that but while
all this is happening right the power of
the dreaming celestial is coalescing the
dreamy celestial is slowly beginning the
process of coming to it's all being
observed by hank pym and janet van dyne
right two of the avengers because it's
all causing seismic activity out in san
francisco now the crazy thing about this
is that once enough energy is coalesced
and the the process is completed and
basically the dreaming celestial rises
as it stands it's colossal now initially
as it appears it's completely black now
the funny thing about this is they talk
about the dreaming celestial as being
something that's golden the whole idea
behind this though is that once you have
icarus and cersei and then these guys
who essentially show up on the scene
that they realize what's really going on
here is once the rays of the sun hit the
dreaming celestial that's when it will
turn gold right it just kind of returns
back to its normal form the idea of it
being black largely seems to be both
symbolic and literal in the sense that
it was kind of cast down into the earth
its color was changed to basically
illustrate that it was an outlier it's a
cast out celestial it's not part of the
greater celestial host and instead being
locked here seems to kind of taken its
color away of course with the sun rising
and absorbing all those energies into
itself it returns it back to its normal
color there is a bit of a fight that
breaks out between the deviants and the
eternals nothing major here right it's
not a great big huge conflict it's kind
of cool to see icarus uses the ability
to shoot energy from his eyes to
overcome these these deviants to a
degree and then some of them are turned
into like a tree right like they're
merged together into a tree and like
that's basically it just kind of locked
there kept there and just left in that
stasis but once the light hits the uh
hits the dreaming celestial and turns
them gold a couple things happened the
first is that on the blue area of the
moon the watcher who sees everything
looks away because the watcher realizes
what the threat of the rise of the
dreaming celestial truly represents the
other thing that happens is that all the
way halfway across the entirety of the
milky way galaxy where galactus is in
the process of beginning to consume an
entire world he senses the arrival of
the dreaming celestial and he gets
scared right this is one of the very few
things that scares galactus now it's
only a single page it's not overly
complex but this is enormous because
what we're talking about here are people
with just astronomical levels of power
to the layman right to the average
individual the normal human living on
earth there's no differentiation between
what the watcher can do and what
galactus can do right it's just their
power is just that high up there but
once you get up on their level and we're
looking at it from really a more even
direction there's huge differences in
what they're capable of but their power
is so extreme reality warping the
ability to create life different things
like that yet despite the power they
have the ability to manipulate and
control cosmic energies on that scale
their power is dwarfed by that of the
dreaming celestial he's just that far
beyond all these guys and depending on
what fan you talk to and i'm one of them
the power of the dreaming celestial can
rival that of eternity depending on the
situation he's just that astronomically
powerful but in the midst of this whole
thing kind of switching back to earth
with with hank pym and janet van dyne
basically contacting iron man and
telling him what's happening they arrive
on the scene now what you get here is a
bit of a skirmish between the eternals
and these avengers but it's kind of
funny because this battle is no measure
of a battle at all like quite literally
athena goes running up on iron man and
shuts the suit down like that right i
mean it's like like literally she runs
up on him and it's just like done right
she shuts his suit down and then sends
him crashing into the earth and then in
turn icarus basically uses his ability
to control minds on hank pym and is like
just stand here right now i know it's
not the most exciting thing there ever
was but it is cool to see because what
this does is it actually gives you an
idea of what the avengers are capable of
or at least what they're incapable of in
the face of the eternals the eternals
were designed to be these angelic
near-god-like beings who were capable of
virtually anything so long as it falls
in the purview of being able to
manipulate cosmic energies the avengers
pale in comparison to these guys the
only person that i could see who would
really stand a chance against the
eternals as long as the fight went on
long enough would be the incredible hulk
and only because of the fact that the
hulk just keeps getting stronger as time
goes on beyond that most anybody would
would lose to the eternals in an actual
physical fight now once you start
introducing like the higher levels of
thor like if you were to enter into like
the berserker state right the warriors
madness well then that totally changes
things right that starts to shift things
up but just thor walking around with his
hammer i have a hard time believing he'd
be able to successfully go toe to toe
against like 100 eternals right they
would just overpower him especially if
they went into the unimine state that
would basically end everything but as it
stands right now the the avengers are
basically just overpowered quite readily
and it's kind of a funny thing because
what you have here in the midst of all
this right while you have so you have
cersei and you got icarus talking and
you have hank pam watching it all unfold
that you actually see the dreaming
celestial stand up and that's when you
realize just how big the dreamy
celestial is this guy's half a mile tall
now here's one thing to understand when
it comes to these guys celestials do not
have a finite size the size they give us
the size that we see them in is usually
done just because of the fact that it
makes it easier to see what's actually
happening celestials can be any size
they want to be and we've seen
celestials that can be like 25 000 feet
tall that's how tall they want to be but
in reality if the celestials showed up
on earth and you saw a conversation
between the celestials and like anybody
else it wouldn't be very interesting if
all you saw was like iron man talking to
a celestial's boot because he's nowhere
near as tall as the celestial's shoe and
so that's why more often than not when
you see the celestials they're drawn to
be large enough to where it really gives
you context in terms of just how big and
imposing and powerful they are but
they're not drawn so tall that it just
comes off as weird and so during this
time because of what's going on if you
do have makari who wakes up but then you
also have icarus who actually travels to
try to speak to the dreaming celestial
and then of course you have zeros and
those guys who show up and they're like
what are you doing man like ajax is the
one who talks to celestial's icarus stop
being a weirdo then what you also have
is basically druid and and zuros and
athena and these guys who essentially
form a eunum could a unimine destroy a
celestial i don't really think so they
could destroy mostly anybody else on
earth outside of like super high level
reality warpers but the unimine is only
ever really brought together when like a
massive calamity or decision needs to be
made in this instance it is the unimine
communicating with the dreaming
celestial the crazy thing about this is
that once the unimine emerges it's
immediately shut down by the dreaming
celestial because the dreaming celestial
has no interest in talking to the human
mind now the other reason why the
unimine is formed here is because in and
of themselves if icarus were to actually
try to talk to the dreaming celestial it
would probably drive him insane and so
basically the the unimine is able to
communicate with celestials because it's
the only real way for them to handle
what is celestial saying without going
crazy in the process and so where ajax
is actually rejected by the dreaming
celestial one is taken as a personal
offense because it flies in the face of
the role that's always been his the
second thing that happens here is that
makari is awakened but the dreaming
celestial chooses to speak directly to
him initially it takes the form of
cersei because you know they've been on
again off again you know i mean over the
course of a million years he ended up
finding yourself dating the same person
a few times you know maybe they change
who knows whatever the case is that the
dreaming celestial actually tells makari
a few things the first is that the
dreaming celestial created makari that
unlike the other eternals who were
basically created by nazar the
calculator right one of the celestials
who ended up creating the eternals that
tiamu the dreaming celestial had
actually created a few beings out there
one of which was makari now we're not
really told explicitly why it is the
dreaming celestial created makari the
important thing here though is that with
the dreaming celestial awakening this
begins the process of what is
essentially the calling that this sent
out a beacon essentially to the horde
that the planet earth is ready to be
cold right ready to be destroyed all
life on it eliminated and so it'll take
quite some time for the for the cord to
get here and the dreamy celestial simply
just says because the universe is a
massive place right and even at like
transluminal speed right traveling
faster than light it'll take him a while
to get here in that time i'm going to
stand and i'm going to watch right i'm
going to observe and then at a future
point in time i will judge this world
and i will decide whether or not this
world should be allowed to live or will
be destroyed that's one of the cool
things here now that's one of the more
important aspects of the dreamy
celestial because that will become very
important in terms of his character's
progression but makari will be the
speaker for the dreaming celestial on
earth now that's one of the cool things
about this right when you're a celestial
you are ancient you've been around for
billions and billions and billions of
years so for a celestial to just stand
there and observe the earth that's no
time at all right i mean that's me
saying what's up guys that's literally
it right i mean like no time passes for
this thing it's a blink of an eye in
terms of its overall existence but for
the occupants on earth they have no idea
how long this is going to go on for i
mean i guess they have until the horde
arrives so that's their window but we're
not given a time in reality there's no
real quantification that's given here he
doesn't say like i'm going to watch your
world and then i'll come to a conclusion
after a while depending on you know
things that have happened what he does
say is that in the time that he was
waking up that he was watching the world
he was looking at everything that was
happening that when he started the
process of waking up then he basically
started absorbing like radio waves and
he started absorbing television signals
and even the internet and he even read
the bible all for the purpose of trying
to understand or trying to get a better
idea of how everything exists here the
funny thing about this is that once
everybody kind of starts to wake up when
the dreamy celestial tells makari by the
way iron man's basically faking dead
over there you know they're like are you
really faking dead he's like i mean yeah
but i was just trying to see what was
going on you know trying to get a better
understanding of what's happening that
iron man's initial response is okay does
this thing really have the ability to
destroy the world and the eternals are
like oh yeah man like i mean this thing
is i mean you're talking about like the
dreaming celestial right like the
ability to destroy the world is nothing
for this guy right i mean this guy could
destroy whole galaxies if he wanted to i
mean this dude goes toe-to-toe or could
go toe-to-toe with some of the most
powerful cosmic entities some of which
you've heard of and some of which you
haven't but rest assured if this guy
wanted to destroy the world it would
take no energy for him to do it and so
the response of iron man is like well
then we have to fight it we have to find
some way to remove it and the response
of the eternals are like are you stupid
man like literally this guy could just
wipe out the whole world right i mean
like there's nothing you could do to
this guy you can't hurt it you can't
affect it nothing you do to the dreaming
celestial would even draw its its
interest in you right i mean it's it's
no it's like a bug crawling on you while
you're sleeping you're not going to
notice it right it's just it's
nothing you can do can hurt this guy
iron man i mean i guess sure if they
gather the infinity stones right i mean
yeah but like outside of that nothing
iron man could do to could bring any
harm to the sky i mean following that
you do have this bit of a discussion
where iron man's like okay well now that
you guys are here you guys have to
register right because civil war i mean
it's kind of like iron man really dude
and that's even what the eternals say
they're like all right look man i mean
we're entertaining your presence here
iron man but understand i mean you're
telling us we have to register if you
saw two groups of children arguing over
which one of them could play in some
waste ground would you really choose
sides you know and that's one of the
crazy things about that is because the
eternals just see themselves as being so
far beyond humanity that like the the
squabbles of humans on earth over
whether or not people are registering to
be superheroes barely even concerns them
well they're like we've got much bigger
things like literally there's a half
mile tall golden statue standing here in
in san francisco and another energy
source like another enemy is gonna come
here potentially to wipe out everything
in this part of the galaxy and your
concern is whether or not we're
registered to be superheroes come on man
it's probably the most condemning
explanation of the the nonsensical
nature of superhuman registration right
i mean it's one of those crazy things
and so during this time what you
actually end up having is the deviants
who show up here right now the deviants
really are looking at this as a way to
destroy what's left of the eternals
right the blood feud never went away and
so the deviants are like we stand the
best possible chance right now if we
were ever going to destroy the eternals
right they've got four numbers they got
four to their number they got four
eternals that's all they have the other
96 are out there somewhere in the world
and they don't know that they're
eternals and if these four are destroyed
those eternals will never realize their
eternals right so if we destroy these
these four we've got six thousand of us
if we destroy these four then like it's
cool everything is copacetic and so what
you actually get here is this really
really cool bit of a challenge from
makari right this guy who can just run
super fast he says okay so here's the
deal right here's what's gonna happen he
says i'm gonna give you a shot right i'm
gonna give you three chances to hit me
if you can hit me in one of those three
shots then i will i will i will like
we'll we'll call it a day right like
i'll sacrifice to you you guys you guys
take us you know and everything's done
and over right like we're gone forever
that's the end of that but if i hit you
once all of you guys go right all of you
guys leave and so the challenge is
initially accepted by this guy craw
right who's just kind of you know the
leader of the deviants at the moment
he's kind of like okay let's just see
what happens here right let's let's just
let's just see what goes on here and so
while that happens and makari
demonstrates his power facing off
against some of the deviants you
actually have zoros who quickly leaves
he ends up going to find uh find sprite
as he's basically trying to escape any
judgment from the eternals themselves
once he tracks him down he's basically
like you do know what's gonna happen
here right like you you took all of our
powers away you convince us that we're
human right i mean you modifying and
potentially unleashing what is basically
the dreaming celestial all this happened
because of you you have to stand for
this right and so what actually ends up
happening here is he basically breaks
the neck of sprite now sprite will
eventually be reborn as an eternal but
at the moment sprite's destroyed here
right sprite's basically dead and out of
the picture kind of the pricey pace and
so once you kind of get back to
everything that's going on you actually
have this attempt by uh by craw the
leader of the deviants to take out
makari and it doesn't work right i mean
of course because makari's so fast he
can't hit it and then he says okay fine
here's my one hit and he kneels before
him and he says chop off my head if you
can cut out like like cut off my head
right now and that'll that'll basically
end everything and so what's been going
on here kind of behind the scenes is
that with the other deviants who were
there at the beginning of all this they
were referring to makari as what was
basically called the scadrotch i think
is how you pronounce raskadrak the whole
point behind that that the reason why
that name is given is because it means
he's possessed by the spirit of a
celestial and in a lot of ways that's
true he's the speaker for the the
dreaming celestial and so to attack
someone who possesses or potentially
possesses the power of a celestial or at
the very least is a speaker for a
celestial would be a massive affront
right while they don't really know
exactly what would happen the concern of
raw is that if they did do that the
dreaming celestia would destroy what's
left of them right and they don't want
to see themselves destroyed by a
celestial because there's nothing they
could do to fight against it the other
part of this though is he's like if you
really are skydrotch then we have what's
called the skydrotch's doom right
basically all who love you will hate you
all who revere you will despise you all
that you care for will be destroyed only
when it ends can there be a beginning so
basically saying that like the idea of
makari being a speaker for the dreaming
celestial while he considers it an honor
the deviants consider it a curse that
everything he loves and knows will
basically be destroyed and in fact this
hits him so hard that he stands there
out in the ice for two weeks mulling the
whole thing over right just like
thinking the whole thing over trying to
figure out what what he thinks and and
how it impacts him if there's any truth
to it whether or not what he's
experiencing as being the voice of the
dreamy celestial really is an honorable
thing as he believes it is he's more
curious about it too because this is
fairly new he's never experienced
anything like this before and so the way
this ends is basically xeros tasked
icarus with going out into the world and
finding the other 96 eternals right
waking up the other 90 eternals that
exist out there and basically bringing
them back which of course haman and
makari end up doing what this does is a
segways directly into the story by
charles noff which most of you guys know
because you've heard of like the the
fulcrum and all that kind of stuff
that's where all that comes into play
right that's how all that comes into
existence when the horde actually shows
up and when i'm not gonna spoil too much
but a lot of really cool things happen
there kind of a fun fact it was written
about two years after this story ended
and it actually tied into the x-men
manifest destiny storyline which was
really really cool but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace